good to meet you steve i like your
background
uh thank you i was gonna make a joke but
i'll just say thank you um
so uh because no one is watching i am
just curious which of your four emmys is
your favorite
i mean they're all as
shiny and pointy as each other and um
yeah it was
an amazing experience to win
you know
it's very we have a very different uh
approach in britain we don't really like
winning things it seems a bit vulgar so
it's
fun to be in the states where people
celebrate winning
and uh are happy for you
i i won't press you any further um the
series uh first of all congrats on the
series i i have a bunch of questions um
how did you decide on eight episodes was
it ever gonna be less or more
um
i thought eight was a good number i mean
there was a lot to get in there was 27
years of
events um
but i felt like i don't know how many
you've seen of them i've seen four
okay yeah so the first four are pretty
much happen all within quite a narrow
time frame because i really want people
to get invested in the characters and
their relationship and
and kind of
get to know that world
and then
i think as so often often happens in
life the next four
we really race through the years and
marty is to kind of
mirror
marty's feeling of just losing track of
time and not kind of realizing where all
that time goes
uh which is a feeling i'm familiar with
and we kind of play with time we go
backwards and forwards a bit in some of
the episodes in the in the next block
so it seemed like a good
a good balance um
and yeah i think i think eight is a is a
good number i think um
you know there's a couple of episodes
without phyllis and we miss her and so
it's great
to get her back in at the end as well
um what was the toughest stuff that
ended up what was the toughest stuff to
pull off with the time and budget that
you had
i mean we were filming during the
pandemic so that was
immediately
complicated
um
and because of that we were filming la
for new york so that also brings a whole
bunch of
problems
um
so in practical terms those were the
tough things and i think on a creative
level
just wanting to make sure
that i
told the story fairly that i didn't
make any judgments on any of the
characters that i let the audience
decide for themselves
and you know give each character a kind
of
treat them with compassion and not sort
of label or blame anyone
uh what's interesting for me when i
heard about this story and i heard you
guys were gonna make it i'm like how are
they to portray like who
this can't be true like how does a
psychologist take over someone's life
and then as i was watching the series
i'm like oh it happens tiny little bits
each time
and then all of a sudden you don't even
realize anyway i'm giving you a
compliment but it's um i guess this
could happen to almost anyone you know
the way that that's yeah
yeah could you sort of talk about that
yeah i totally agree i think
often people's response to the podcast
was what a banana story that would never
happen to me and i kind of thought
i don't think that's true i think that
could happen to anyone and i think
marty i think it's a really universal
story because marty's experiences of
bereavement of anxiety of
splitting up
in a relationship you know they're
things we've all experienced
and in the last 19 months with the
pandemic with lockdown we've also
all experienced feeling isolated and
uncertain about the future and afraid
so i feel like
we could all be marty we in a vulnerable
moment we could all be marty and we've
all had
relationships whether with family
members or
friendships or romantic relationships
that
have started really well
and then there are a few alarm bells a
few red flags but you kind of
you miss them or you ignore them or you
the person wins you around and paul rudd
is just so good at charming us again
every time we start to doubt him
so i i think you're exactly right it
could happen to
any of us
and it's very hard
to notice when it's happening and then
once you're in deep it's incredibly hard
to get out of it
was there anything when you were
researching and getting ready to make it
that you
heard that just really shocked you just
really took you back
i think because i did feel some weird
maybe because i have always written for
very unlikable irredeemable characters i
did have this weird
sympathy for ike
when i heard that he had also
encouraged other patients to cut off
ties with their families and
that other patients had left him money
in their will
i found that pretty hard to get back
from
but
yeah i completely agree um i i love
learning about the behind the scenes of
the making of the series besides the
covet of it all um what do you think
might surprise people to learn about the
making of the show i mean i don't know
about the making of it um
but i think what will surprise people is
they'll see it's a will and paul show
and they might be expecting a kind of
bro comedy and what actually they're
getting as an incredibly
moving and emotional
and tragic story that
you know i think both actors
give extraordinary performances very
moving performances and i think that
might take people by surprise
um i completely agree i'm also curious
how many takes were ruined because they
weren't happy with their accent
well uh there are a lot of takes ruined
because they kept making each other
laugh
um
you know it's very tricky being a
british person and i'm not the greatest
person to judge their accents but they
kept each other in check there were a
lot of new yorkers on set so uh they
were being policed
um by people who were much more
in a much better position than me to
to know if their accent was correct or
not
how does it work because obviously this
is streaming so you don't really have to
hit like certain time marks in terms of
commercials or whatever so how did you
end up with a lot of deleted scenes was
it um
did you you know what i mean like what
was it like in the editing room
it was very liberating actually that is
the joy of of writing something for
apple or for any streamer
and that i i said to them what i really
want to do is write
like a 30 minute and then
let it breathe and let and keep
everything and not have to make those
heartbreaking cuts where we lose
beautiful character pieces or
important plot moments and so that's
what we did so most episodes are kind of
40 to 45 minutes long
and that was that's a great
length you know that's you can pack a
lot in but you can also
take your time to enjoy
enjoy the moments and enjoy the
performances
i completely agree i want to say
congrats on what i've seen thus far
can't wait to finish thank you so much
for your time
thank you very much indeed
you